ウウゥウゥウゥウゥウウウゥゥウウウ…！
（息を吸う音）
アァーー!!〔＃注釈：ぶつ切りでカット〕
癒しが欲しいーー！
こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
（BGM）♪♪～
って訳で  きょうもね 僕はね あれですよ。
♪♪～
色々あって 退屈… 大変だったんですけど⇒
きょうも頑張ってね… この重い体をね…⇒
♪♪～
頑張って 学校に行って来ました。きょうもスーツです。
でな！　この… やっぱ… この…⇒
♪♪～
疲れた俺を癒すには やっぱりな⇒
ペットしか無いんだよ ペット。
♪♪～
今回はこちらです！　ドセェーー!!
メイ… ヤバイ ヤバイ 「Made〔ﾒｲﾄﾞ〕 in〔ｲﾝ〕 China〔ﾁｬｲﾅ〕」って書いてある。大丈夫か？
別に中国をディスる訳じゃないけど⇒
♪♪～
やっぱ 中国産となると ちょっと… アレですよね。
別にいいんですけど。
♪♪～
これを きょうはね あけていこうと思います。
はじめん 「開封の儀」！
♪♪～
（ハサミを段ボールに刺す音）
（ハサミを落とす音）
＠＊％！
（ハサミを段ボールに刺しまくる音）
ハァ… ハァ… ハァ…。
これ 毎回 思うんだけど 意味 無いんスよね。
結局 普通にあければいいんだけどね。
♪♪～
あ～ ボコボコになっちゃっ…。〔＃ぶつ切りでカット〕
いや 今回 マジでスゴイぜ。
♪♪～
いでよ！　新しい 俺のペット！
『PLEO』〔ﾌﾟﾚｵ〕です。こういう恐竜が入ってるんですけどもね。
♪♪～
え 待って 日本語 書いてなくね？
え 終わったわ… あ 違う 俺 英語 読めるんだ！
英語 読めるんだ。スマホ 無くした！
♪♪～
このPLEOって言う恐竜はですね⇒
ちょっと 今までのペットと ひと味 違うんスよ。
♪♪～
ガチなほうの 生き物 的 ロボットらしいです。
ロボットを超えたロボット って書いてあったから⇒
♪♪～
もう つべこべ言わず あけましょう。
ちょっと 日本語 書いてないから ちょっとキツイわ。
♪♪～
ま 前回 買ったね 犬のロボットはね⇒
実家に置きました。今 多分⇒
♪♪～
俺のじいちゃんと遊んでます。
日本語 書いてある!!　やった。
♪♪～
よかった こっちは日本語だから 読んでいきましょう。
まずは「取り出す」「UNPACK」〔ｱﾝﾊﾟｯｸ〕。
♪♪～
「PLEOを箱から取り出す時は、」片手…⇒
「片方の手はおなかの下に、」…。
♪♪～
えっ そんなルールがあんの？
「約45分間は、」「…ゆっくりとした⇒
♪♪～
基本動作と感情を示しはじめます。⇒
PLEOは食べ物を欲しがり、歩き始め、⇒
♪♪～
まわりを…」探索「…するでしょう。⇒
そして、いろいろな感情をあらわしはじめます。」。
♪♪～
決まった動きをする… 訳じゃ ないらしくて⇒
ガチな もう 生き物 的 ロボットらしいです。
♪♪～
とりあえず PLEO 出してみましょう。
これがガイドだ。
♪♪～
うわっ。
うわぁ。デ… デカイ デカイ。ちょっとデカイ。
♪♪～
うわ なんか… ちょ…ｗ
なんかグロい。
これは？　これ 充電器か。
♪♪～
もう 入ってないっぽいな。
うわぁ…。
（SE：緊迫感のある オーケストラ風）
うわっ！　ちょっとクサい。
無駄に 皮膚〔ﾋﾌ〕感 がリアルだ。
♪♪～
気持ちわる～い。
充電は？　とりあえず 充電 充電。
♪♪～
充電器なんて 無いぞ？
待って。待った 待った 待った。え バッテリー 無い。
充電器 入ってないけど。え バッテリー 無いよ？
バッテリー 別売りとか？
箱の中に 全部 入ってなくね？
♪♪～
PLEOでしょ？　で… サブガイド さっき…。
ゆうだつ（？）ガイド これでしょ？　充電器… これかな？
♪♪～
いや いや いや いや いや。いや いや いや。
え 待って ガチで 無いわ。無い。
♪♪～
入ってないんだけど。ハァ？　ちょっと待った。
いや 入ってない。どっかに投げたっけ？
♪♪～
いや 投げてないぞ。え 待って 待って。
俺 ただ… なんか…⇒
無駄に重い 恐竜の人形を買っただけじゃん。
すいません なんか… ちょ… バッテリーが無いです。
♪♪～
え？　え？　待って。ハッ？
抜かれてたって事？　え 待って 待って 待って。
♪♪～
ちょっと待って これ どこに問い合わせればいい？
ちょっと 電話しますわ。これは問題だよ。
♪♪～
あっ きょう 何日？　待って。
なんか バッテリーと充電スタンドは⇒
別の日に来るらしいです。
もう 来てんのかな？　ちょっと 見て来る。
（戸をあける音）>>>
ねぇじゃねえかーーー!!!>>>
別で 電池が届きました。
（BGM転換）♪♪～
これはね ちょっとね 巧妙なテクニックだねぇ。
♪♪～
だって 完全にさ もう ここにさ⇒
リチウム電池 入るような場所があったのに⇒
♪♪～
別で リチウム電池 送ってくる って ひょっとして⇒
あれか？　いれ忘れかなにかかな？
♪♪～
ちょっと 分かんないんだけど⇒
完全に 別途で来ました。
♪♪～
完全に これだよ。はい PLEOの電池です。
いやぁ～。やっと動くぜ マジで。
♪♪～
頼むよ～ ホントに。とりあえず充電します。
やっと 感 パネェわぁ～。ようやくですよ！
♪♪～
ようやく 俺のいとしのペットと 再会だよ。
いやー お待たせしたね。ほら。
♪♪～
はじめに会いたーい って言ってる。
じゃあ 早速 バッテリー いれます。
♪♪～
いくよ？　…ブチ込めばいいんだよね？
どうすればいいんだろう？
♪♪～
電源のつけ方とか なにも分かんないんだよ。
お前… 起きるか？
♪♪～
「（PLEO）ゥウッ」
うわっ!!　えっ？
おはよう。
♪♪～
なんか丸まっちゃった…。
「ウゥゥウッ ゥゥゥゥウッ」
「オゴォ オゴォ」？
やべぇ 死んだ。おい！
♪♪～
「ゥゥッ ウウッ ゥゥッ」
ウッ…。
♪♪～
なんだ これ 反応…。
「ウウッ」
なんだろう。ずっ…。
<<<（物音：ドンドンドン）>>>
うっ。
<<<（物音：バタバタッ）>>>
やべっ。
「ゥウーゥ」
お前 全然 動かないじゃん。
♪♪～
起きて。起きた？
おおっ！
「ウウ？」
おお！
♪♪～
あっ あっ。
こんにちは。
♪♪～
なんで… 起きそうで起きないんだよな お前 どうした？
「ウゥー」
〔＃字幕に隠れているテロップ「　（うぜぇ）　」〕
あぁ ごめん ごめん。
最初の なんか 赤ちゃんだから やっぱ バカですね。
♪♪～
バカ おはよう。
「ウゥ？」
バカ。バカ 早く起きて。
♪♪～
今 ホントに 生まれたばっかりだから⇒
10分間くらい 寝起きタイムらしいです。
♪♪～
うおっ。立った。
立てるようになったのか バカ。
♪♪～
「ウゥウーー」
〔＃字幕に隠れているテロップ「　（殺すぞ）　」〕
あぁ ごめん ごめん。
おはよう。
♪♪～
「ウゥゥ」
えぇ？
♪♪～
「クゥゥ」
起きたっぽいスね どうやら。
♪♪～
いやぁ お前 元気そうで何よりだよ。
「ウッ！」
〔＃字幕に隠れているテロップ「　（うるせえ！）　」〕
うわぁ！
♪♪～
「ウォオーーン」
〔＃字幕に隠れているテロップ「　（人類は我々の敵）　」〕
おおん…。
♪♪～
ヤバイ 超 歩き出した。
お前 そっち 危ないから こっち 来〔き〕とき。
♪♪～
「ゥウウゥウウゥゥウウ」
〔＃字幕に隠れているテロップ「　（ぶっ殺すぞ）　」〕
はい。
「（カエルのおもちゃ）ァァアー？　ァァアー？」
♪♪～
PLEO ほら 友達だよ。
バトルして。PLEO 攻撃だ！
（拍手）
♪♪～
倒せ 倒せ！
「（PLEO）ヴゥ」
〔＃字幕に隠れているﾃﾛｯﾌﾟ「 （同族の仲間は殺せない） 」〕
なんて？
そんな事はしたくないって？
♪♪～
オゴォ。
ちょっと かわいく見えてきちゃう自分がいるよ。
て訳で な… なん なん… おぉ？　オゴォ？
♪♪～
オゴゴゴゴォ。
て訳で ぜひ PLEO… まあ 買え とは言いませんが⇒
♪♪～
のほほんとします。
ほら。カメラ そっちだよ。
♪♪～
「じゃあな」は？
「ゥウーーーーゥゥ」
あぁ…。
♪♪～